I think Kanye is making great music I
think Radiohead is making great music I
think vice is making great music I think
I think jay-z is making great music I
think Lupe Fiasco is making great music
I think there's a range of artists I
think are really doing what I what I try
to do and that is try to push the
boundaries try to make something special
try to make something with artistic
integrity that is cool and fresh and new
and those artists are respect hello who
knows I you know some some some people
one-hit wonders but that one hit stands
the test of time you know so we'll see
i'm not good at judging that but i think
songs that last are the songs that have
a message that is universal in that and
that isn't specific to that moment but
it's something that touches a you know a
human emotion that it is universal so I
think there are songs that are like that
that are going to stay around that have
a great melody that has have a sound
that isn't going to feel dated in you
know five or ten years and those songs
are going to last and songs can last
sometimes longer than artists can last
and an artists usually last partly
because of the music they create but
also because of who they are do they
have the dedication do they have the you
know continuing ability to challenge
himself and to be ambitious and too I
don't know to in the face of
disappointment sometimes in the face of
a letdown to keep being persistent only
certain people have that and only
certain people last partly because of
that some people last on the same songs
they've been touring on for you know 20
years and they just keep trying those
songs but they last because they may
inch to you know keep themselves
together they don't get caught up in
whatever drugs or whatever you know
brings a lot of people down they don't
get too caught up in it and they just
continue to persist and and and continue
to entertain the crowds and to not let
them down and they last you know
hopefully I'll be around for a long time
performing these songs and continuing to
make new songs and continue to perform
other song that's what it I think most
artists want